Welcome to the final
session of
the morning, before
the lunch break,
with, Vanessa Lopez of IBM
Research Ireland.
Vanessa's research
interests are
to investigate and envision
technologies to
better understand
human needs and support us as
a society to target complex
problems in
the health and social
care domain, in
particular using
a combination of semantic,
natural language,
and learning technologies
to capture,
integrate, search,
and query diverse
data and apply
it to solve real challenges,
like for integrated care,
to support the care
of the most
vulnerable citizens,
and to ultimately obtain,
better outcomes.
And Vanessa is the,
research scientist
and manager,
within the,
AI for health and
social care,
area of IBM.
So a a very warm welcome to,
Vanessa and, and over to you.
Hi, everybody.
Thank you so much
for the nice intro.
So, yeah, I am a resource
scientist and
manager for the last
eight years at IBM Research in
the lab in Ireland.
And people here have,
lots of different
backgrounds.
Mine is actually academic.
I used to be in
the Open University
in KMI. But,
since I am in IBM
in our team,
we have done a lot of work on
applying research
to the integrated
health and social
care domain.
So I'm really glad to be here
to share with you
this research
work that we have done jointly
with my team at,
IBM Research Europe
and with IBM
Watson Health. Both teams are
collocated in Dublin,
and we have a mighty
common mission,
which is to bring AI to help
transform how the health care
systems of the future
will grow.
The group peak
here is obviously
from the old days
where we could
get together in person.
And here, I'll talk,
miss mostly about
my experience
and perspective
perspectives on
using knowledge
graph to address
significant societal problems
in the health care industry in
two projects. One that we work
on for almost three years to
combat fraud, waste,
and abuse to protect people
public health problems,
and a second new
or exploratory
one to understand
the impact of
social problems
to drive positive
health. There are not yet AI
strong offerings in the human
and health services space.
And this is because
while everyone
thinks that this is a real
competitive differentiator,
bringing AI innovations
is really hard.
And embedding AI
requires longer
efforts than classical product
timelines. It
requires validating
what is feasible,
what is the impact of false
negatives and false positive,
understand
the customization effort,
and the time to
market to market
assistance. So it
requires a little
bit less, and it needs to be
driven very much
by the expertise
from the subject
matter experts.
Those are our SMEs.
And our SMEs in particular,
they work with
the government,
and they bring experience from
the Medicare and the Medicaid
health programs in the US.
So before I deep dive,
one may ask why
Knowledge Graph.
So health care and program
integrity in particular,
they are very complex domains
where science and
AI can really
make a difference.
It has a direct impact
on people's life,
and huge amounts of money are
spent globally.
There have been actually lots
of advancements
on the scientific
community by building
models of disease,
progression, and outcomes.
However, the impact of those
models has been
somehow limited.
Maybe maybe because the models
are silo in
the source of data,
they are silo in the specific
use case or in
a specific disease,
and isolated models provide
isolated predictions.
And they do not support very
well
the comprehensive insights
that you need behind complex
decisions and
the best practice
patterns among health care
providers and
payers that remain
hidden in the data.
So analyst graph
emerge as a unifying
technology that may facilitate
creating interconnected models
so we get better
at characterizing
and predicting.
Our long term goal
is to empower
care professionals
with augmented
AI so they can
ultimately improve
patient outcomes at
a sustainable cost,
which is a very
ambitious goal.
And this talk is
about our journey
at IBM Research.
And as a spoiler,
we are still far from solving
many of the challenges,
starting with proving how well
it can scale in a real world
environment. So a top priority
by the World
Health Organization
is to reduce disparities on
the delivery of
health care and
to ensure a fair
distribution of funds,
that there is
enough for everyone
in need to get
the services that
they are entitled for.
Even more at this COVID time
when the needs
are so great and
the funding is stretched,
it is key that
the money intended
for vital public
health programs
are not great by intentional
fraud or by unintentionally
providing services that are
unnecessary or they
are inconsistent
with good medical practices or
in the worst case,
even harmful to patients.
So just to make
clear that program
integrity is not about
limiting funding.
It is about making sure that
the money goes where needed.
At to combat fraud, waste,
and abuse is a huge market.
In the US alone,
health care fraud
losses are in
the tens of billions
each year.
These are shocking
amounts because
of bus toasters and
bus providers,
and these numbers
indicate a significant
market opportunity.
So in this scenario,
the providers
rendering services
to patient submit claims to
the state health programs,
such as Medicare and Medicaid
so they can get reimbursed.
And the payers know how much
the providers are spending,
but they don't know if this is
in compliance to regulations
which are described in policy
or how much is lost
to fraud, waste,
and abuse.
So the investigation units,
they validate the integrity of
these claims submitted by
providers so they can recover
overpayments for claims that
infringe policy.
This is a labor
intense and an error
prone task. To build a case,
the investigators
had to review
the policy, and then they had
to talk to the data analyst to
query the claim data,
and they go back
and forth till
they find what they need.
They manually encode some
algorithms on top
of the claim data,
but most of the stuff
in the policy,
it doesn't get automated.
So due to
the overwhelming volume
of policies and claims,
most of the systematic
fraud or
waste is never surfaced.
So the policy is written down
in very large text documents
that is describing
what the providers
should be doing,
And all information about what
providers are
actually doing is
in the structured claim data.
So state of the art
fraud, waste,
and abuse detection is data
driven on top of
the structured claims,
for example, to
identify providers
with anomalous patterns.
But being another
layer does not
always mean a provider
is fraudulent.
And even if so,
it is not enough
to know a provider
is fraudulent. Investigators
need to tie
the clients for this
provider to
the policy legislation
to build a case.
And these efforts
are not always
successful. The
policy may turn
out to be too vague
to be enforced,
and providers are
confused about
what they should be doing on
the recoverables recoverable
amounts too little to warrant
any action. So we thought it
will be very powerful to bring
this together, and
we are the first
ones to automate
the process of
identifying claims
at risk based
on policy text.
So the unique value lies first
on using NLP and AI
for the automatic
extraction of the actionable
knowledge from the policy.
It converts
the policy text into
a knowledge base of benefits
rules that can be
directly applied
to review claims
against policy.
And these human and machine
consumable rules,
they provide
a common interpretation
of the policy, which can be
shared across the team and
investigators. And that that
allows a more thorough,
transparent,
and consistent review.
So this benefit benefit rules
that are extracted
from policies,
they are reviewed
by the SMEs,
our subject matter experts,
before they execute
the mobile claims.
And this is a significant
differentiator. It empowers
the investigators to size and
prioritize the investigations
they may follow based
on the evidence
and on the likelihood
of recovery
from funds and as
well on the policy
by executing those
policy rules
on top of the claims.
And a second big piece is
explainability.
Each label claim
at risk is linked
to the benefit
rule alongside the natural
language part from the policy
text that explains
what is the violation
. So there are many challenges
behind automating the claim
processing from
policy at the scale.
And a core challenge
is to capture
the knowledge
from the text and
to model the domain.
So at the center,
there is an ontology,
which is an evolving
asset that
we created manually with our
experts to bring
to bridge this
conceptualization gap on how
the experts think
about the policy
and how the data is
storing the claims.
The ontology captures
the terminology,
and it makes explicit complex
relations that we
are interested on,
so it guides destruction.
Another challenge is that we
didn't have any label data to
start with. So an important
achievement was engagement and
the validation with the users
early in the development.
So we build basic UI tools to
interact and gather
feedback and
ground truth data
from the experts
and to learn from
that human feedback.
Lastly, we need to
connect the policy
information to the structured
claim data in order to reason
over claims, to quantify,
and explain the violations.
So, overall, this is a new way
that we are
proposing to consume
rules from policy.
And to do so, we have to work
very closely with our
policy as person.
What are the type
of rules most
suitable and of high value?
And this is just here a simple
example from
a dental policy on
a service limitation type of
rule on the number
of units a provider
can bill for
a given service on
a given patient over
a period of times.
So there are many ways ways in
which the policy
text may describe
this criteria,
but with the with the same
underlying semantics.
So after ingesting
the PDF policy,
the second step is
to automatically
identify the concepts and
relations that are expressing
the sentence and to abstract
that into common
reusable patterns
or structure
templates of benefits
rules as they are
modeling the ontology,
like capturing for
which services,
whether they
qualify in eligible
members, whether the limits,
are there any
other requirements
or exclusions.
A knowledge graph is then
automatically populated with
this knowledge funded policy.
And because
automatic knowledge
extraction is really
far from perfect,
human AI collaboration
is crucial
for experts to
review and validate
the strategic rules.
Once that's done,
the last step
connects the policy
information to the structured
claim data.
This is a mapping
and configurable
step that maps conditions and
values from the ontology to
column values on the claims.
So it can execute on top of
claims and label
the claims that
are valid or at risk depending
on the type of rule.
So this is just
to impress with
some boxes, but no worries.
I won't go into detail. Yes.
To give a flavor
here that there
are lots of moving
parts behind
an AI system. And these are
components that
we build on top
of existing technology,
which combines NLP,
Now let's reason
in so we cannot
put the knowledge
base of benefits
rules from the policy and that
the users can review.
And from them, we we can learn
from that feedback
based on deep
learning approaches.
So the instruction
improves over time.
Here, as a sample
on the knowledge
extraction, this is built on
complementary different
technologies,
assistant to perform
various NLP tasks,
like post tagging,
ontology based annotations,
and to strat
functional dependencies
in text. We you
we do that based
on semantic role
labeling functionality,
like what is the action,
who is the agent,
the theme of the context,
and also dependency trees.
These are very
useful representations
for relation
extraction as they
collect entities in a sentence
through label edges.
In some, different strategies
are used to extract those
potentially relevant
textual pot
patterns and expose predicate
argument structures
from the sentence.
And from those,
we build a semantic
graph based
not just of concurrency of
entities in the sentence,
but how the terms
are linguistically
and semantically connected.
So all domain information is
inside ontology,
and this is a a sample
of the subset
of the ontology
that represents
the scheme of
the rule described
in the sample, which is meant
to model a maximum reimburse
amount for a service
for certain
members during
a certain period.
And OA is flexible.
It does not impose
a fixed template,
but the main
constraints can be
defined to ensure semantically
meaningful benefit rules.
Like, for example,
this joint constraint
that tells
that a service cannot be both
a cover applicable service and
an excluded service
in the same
benefit rule.
So the goal is to
populate the ontology
with a knowledge graph with
the benefit rules, if any,
extracted from the text.
So after matching at the level
of entities to
classes, instances,
properties, or data types,
the system search for matches
at the level of patterns,
transforming the text all
dependencies into
graph patterns
in a knowledge graph.
By reasoning over
the anthology,
it can infer
implicit relations
and a path connecting
the entities.
And this is a simple example
where we have
thousand dollars,
which is annotated as
a monetary amount,
and up to, which
matches an ontological
property, which expected range
is monetary amount.
So they are linguistically
connected in the sentence,
and we can also
find a path that
semantically connects them to
build a knowledge graph.
So that's the idea
behind. Right?
And the results is an olive
graph that in all information
needed for these benefit rules
attached to this sentence.
Now the goal is not
just a distraction,
but to empower
the investigators
to interact with the tool and
to build trust in the AI.
So we needed to
hide the complexity
behind this
knowledge graph and
present an unambiguous flat
representation of
a benefit rule.
And on top of those,
that user friendly
representation,
the user can correct
any errors.
And through these
validations,
they are
incrementally building
institutionally institutional
knowledge based
on policy rules
that we can also
use as a ground
truth for evaluation purposes
on one hand. So
we can evaluate
in terms of
precision and recall
and publish results
in conferences.
But, also,
as we work with
SMEs and as this
shared knowledge
base is created,
the question becomes,
how can we learn
from this human
feedback to predict benefit
rules in
a nondeterministic way?
So we use the ground
truth data
to fine tune transfer language
models such as PERT.
Now learning from
a small grown
small ground truth
data is challenging,
so we combine knowledge graph
with this deep
learning approaches,
enhanced with
semantic embeddings
with two goals.
One is classifying
with greater
accuracy the sections
in the policy
that are most likely relevant
with the benefit rule and also
to predict the spans
in a benefit rule.
So to be able to
annotate unseen
mentions of entities
and relations
and to annotate them directly
with relevant relation.
So it is not just
saying that,
let's say, an oral evaluation
in the sample is a service,
but to say that in the context
of this sentence,
it has two roles.
It can be
an applicable service
payable once every
three years,
or it can be a nonreimbursable
service if given at the same
date and other
listed reimbursable
services. So you
can see here,
the structure is
quite complex.
So it is the learning.
So this is work in progress,
but we are getting
preliminary,
potentially good results.
So now to combat
fraud, waste,
and abuse is a huge market,
and it is hard for
humans to scale.
But machines can do it if we
capture the right
knowledge and
the sophistication
in the models.
So to prove
the feasibility and
validate the results,
we build call to
standards with
our investigators.
They manually
select it and hand
coded a set of
twenty representative
algorithms that correspond to
some of our policy rules.
It is a very
limited set for now
because encoding its algorithm
to build the voltage
standard,
it takes
precious investigations
investigators' time.
As for those, the system can
automatically take
the validated
rules to label
claims and quantify
funds at risk with
the same accuracy,
same precision recall of our
SMEs on top of a hundred
million claims.
And this validates
the semantics
behind the model.
See, for example,
rule seven on the table,
it has a relatively
small number
of claims at risk,
but they accounted for very
large amounts of
money and funds
potentially recoverable.
In fact, out of
a hundred million
claims, we can identify almost
five hundred thousand
claims at risk.
That is point
zero five percent
of the claims for a total of
twenty nine million value.
This is pulling needles out of
a haystack. This twenty nine
million is from a small set of
rules selected for
evaluation purposes,
but we have hundreds
of policies
containing hundreds of rules
across areas like
physical therapy,
medical equipment,
behavioral and mental
health, vaccines,
you name it. So the good thing
is that the execution
of claims
is configurable
and transferable.
So there is no need
to write a unique
algorithm to cover each rule.
Given the same
claims as schema,
the rule is executed
on the same
way across benefit rules.
And that's another
advantage. Yes.
So the investigators
can approach
investigation from
multiple angles.
They can search the policy,
relating to suspiciously high
bill services,
and they can see
the payment rules
that have been
extracted on what
policy says.
And they can review them and
publish them into a dashboard
to immediately
visual visualize
how the data looks like based
on those rules and the impact
in terms of invalid claims and
amount of money.
And underneath all
that, the ontology,
what it does, it
provides a shared
interpretation of
the policy and
makes this process of rule
creation more transparent and
comprehensible for
machine and humans.
This increases
the productivity,
basically. It also
provides an abstraction
that allow us to reuse what we
learn in one place
to somewhere
else and minimizes
the gap between
the policy intent with inter
protection interpretation and
the execution, which increase
the confidence
in the rules and
the consistency of how
they are playing.
So we are aiming
to capture more
and more diverse
rules over time
and to interpret more complex
requirements,
like if a service
was medical
medically necessary
that requires linking health
records to claims.
And there are
many opportunities
to apply this technology in
other scenarios,
perhaps to assist pro assist
providers to know
what they need
to attach to claims before
submission so they don't get
rejected by the payers because
of missing information or to
identify gaps in policy so we
can improve the communication
between payers and providers.
And now let me
just briefly move
to other cool exploratory work
in progress. This is on using
knowledge graph
as a foundation
for understanding
the impact of
social determinants of class.
This is a use
case example that
we published very recently on
exploring social drivers of
health during COVID
by leveraging
knowledge graph and
population trends.
But first, what are
social determinants?
So those are all
the things that
are in the fringe
of the traditional
health care system,
but that have
a major influence
on health and are
hugely important
to determine
the treatments with
successful outcomes.
Take, for example,
homeless of poverty.
So they have an impact on
admissions to hospital
and the complications
of a disease and
are often a hidden
driver of cost
behind vulnerable
population. There are many
examples in the news.
Here is million
dollar married.
He was a homeless
alcoholic man
in Nevada. And for ten years,
he was on the streets,
and he ran a medical
bill larger
than anyone in Nevada.
And it is one of
the samples why
social problems may be cheaper
to solve than to ignore.
It costs one
million dollars not
to do something
about malware.
And despite research showing
this strong link between
understanding
social determinants
and health outcomes,
there is a gap in
the market for
orphanings that work with
unstructured tests and that
cover social
determinants of health.
Our goal, not there yet,
but in the past too,
is to bring understanding and
evidence on what is the impact
of tackling social aspects to
improve health outcomes and to
reduce the cost on
populations at risk.
Now when when we
think about COVID,
we first think
about the disease,
the symptoms, how it spread,
how to cure it,
or even the global
economic crisis.
But there are also significant
societal consequences.
COVID basically
escalates the need
of the vulnerable
populations,
and the social
problems are made
worse because of it.
So what we are looking at here
is perhaps the less
study social
and other health concerns
surrounding the pandemic.
Take food insecurity.
You may think of,
several areas
where people have
not access to food,
or you have you have a Spanish
mama that will tell you about
children in Africa
at every meal time.
But in the US, food insecurity
is also a big issue.
People that may live in food
deserts where they only have
access to McDonald's
and fresh,
healthy, real food
is unaffordable
for them. So our contribution
in this paper was
to build a proof
of concept where we monitor
concerning trends in social
determinants that are arising
from COVID and link them to
other potential
health and social
issues to identify
those populations
that are vulnerable
or that are
at risk of becoming vulnerable
during the pandemic.
Now differently from clinical
data where we have
many standards
and terminology,
there is not yet
a taxonomy for
social determinants
of health,
but there is
an ongoing processes.
It is really a big
effort because
the domain is really broad.
So for this purpose,
for evidence
discovery relation
evidence discovery,
we structured
associations from
PubMed between
social and clinical
terms, and we mined those
relations into
a knowledge graph.
To start with,
we look at
the social determinants
that were trending high and
which ones are trending higher
when COVID. In particular,
we look at Google
Trends to get
a glimpse of
the social concerns
on people's mind
during COVID.
We found trends like jobless,
food insecurity,
and shortage,
which coincides
with the lockdown
and thus hardly surprising.
So in a second step,
we look at for those social
trends of interest,
like food insecurity
in scientific
literature, particularly in
PubMed abstract,
to mine the evidence that they
could affect people's health.
So we tag the text in this
abstract with a tool called
MetaMap to highlight concepts
clinical concepts.
And once we have
those sentences
containing both
food insecurity
and other clinical or social
related issue,
we use a birth
based classifier
to annotate the sentence as is
it it has
a positive association
or a negative one
or no correlation
or something more complex.
So for example,
food insecurity is positively
associated with h b a one c.
That is one of the markets
for diabetes.
So we capture those
into a knowledge
graph to build our
first catalog.
And this is this is a graph
between food insecurity and
unemployment with the most
relevant neighbors,
like anxiety,
obesity, depression,
and a bit of noise too.
So we verify some
of these terms
like obesity and coping,
and we also find higher trends
in Google Earth,
which show that we are able to
capture relevant
relations between
the social and the health.
Now, current and
future work is
to keep improving
this relation
identification to catch more
complex relations
and not ratios
so we can assign
weight to the ages.
And the value of
this knowledge
graph is, in fact,
to bring it together
with clinical
records or population records
to create foundations for new
analytic offerings
offerings and
to be able to do
further research
as to quantify the impact of
these relations in clinical
outcomes and to
improve current
test risk models
and identify,
for example, what kind of
interventions we
could have for
those high cost high needs
segments of the population.
In my experience,
using ontologies and
knowledge graph,
they help us really to develop
technologies that are able to
work with an open
set of features
and that they can
be reused and
they can scale to broad domain
knowledge such as including
health records, claims,
social determinants,
and so on.
So we can build
models that are
more human understandable and
machine consumable.
And just to finish,
I hope I convinced you that
health care is one of those
areas where AI
and knowledge can
really have major impact and
that there are lots of open
challenges to keep
researchers happy.
But it is in particular time
that we had
a conversation about
what real benefits users final
users get from the AI systems
and to start designing system
for the users rather
than assuming
that a high accuracy
is sufficient
for them. We need
to define and
measure impact,
and that requires finding this
wow moment where you are able
to go to a user
and tell the story
so you engage them
since the early
stages. In my view,
there are many benefits,
at least in this domain.
Like, for example,
care professionals turnover
turnover is high,
knowledgeable experts are in
short supply, and
there is a need
to share and scale
expertise for
which knowledge
is a good tool.
There is also an aspiration to
support the experts
with explainable
and concise concise
evidence on
the point of care to back up
their decisions.
Like, whatever it
is recommending
interventions or whatever is
identifying ways or improving
policy to reduce health care
disparities. Like,
for example,
you can give fifty blood text
analysis to someone per year,
but that won't
make a difference
in any outcome.
And the evidence is
there in the data.
But in some, it is not much
about what technology
is underneath,
but about empowering
the health
care agencies and
the governments
to reboot society
with a better
way to approach
health care and
a more adaptive
post COVID health
system. And that's the end of
my presentation.
I think, there's
some questions
coming through at the moment.
I can see, a couple
of people typing.
I'll just read
the first one out.
It appears you use OWL,
and you have complex
and explicit
SME rules. Question,
are you using OWL DL?
Which rules engine
do you use?
How do you translate rules
implicit in the ontology to
those you run against
the knowledge
graph? Question
from people. Yeah.
Yeah. That that is,
that is a very good question.
I didn't cover that.
And, yes, we are
using actually all,
behind, so that's how we are
defining the ontology.
But then what we
do is transform
this knowledge
graph into a flat
representation that we store
actually in a post
in a Mongo,
sorry, in a MongoDB.
And it's
a simple representation
where you show just
the conditions
and the values
so that the SMEs
can in a very easy way,
with their own
terminology that
we actually define
in ontology,
curate those those rules.
And then what happened is is
these conditions
and these values,
they are mapped
for to claims,
columns and to claims
values. Right?
So and this is happening in
odontology as well.
That's domain
knowledge that we
live in odontology
saying, for example,
that the service about topical
fluoride describing the policy
corresponds to codes zero zero
one and codes zero zero two as
they are billed
on the claims.
So those that
linkage information
is behind the syntactology,
and we use that to basically
send a set of queries.
So we aggregate the claims.
We filter claims
based on the service
or based on
the period of time.
We apply some
operators like you
have to be between this h and
this h and so on.
So then that executes,
and the selected claims,
they are marked as valid or as
invalid depending on
the type of rule.
So it's it's
a deterministic approach.
What we are now investigating
as well is to be to
use a probabilistic
reasoning engine.
So to be able to execute that
knowledge even in the cases
where maybe we are not fully
sure or fully confident
on the rule.
So there may be rules that we
have a very high
confidence that
they are accurate because they
were validated with
by the users,
all the stuff are not.
So a probabilistic engine will
be a good tool to to
handle those cases,
but that's that's
currently work
in progress. So
integrating a rule
engine is is work
in progress,
and we'll see what
results we get.
Cool. Interesting.
Thanks for that.
Whilst there's
a couple of people
typing questions,
Keith says thank you,
just whilst that's happening,
one of the questions
that came up in,
some of the workshop
shop sessions
was around I don't
know whether
you you may be able
to answer this is,
if someone was
starting to look
at open source
biomedical ontologies,
I guess, what
common ontologies
there are that you
would recommend
working with? Yeah.
So we have, work
a lot with ICD ten.
It's a very medical medical
terminology for, you
know, all these,
like, symptoms,
diagnosis, and so on.
We work a lot as
well with UMLS,
which is a unifying medical
language terminology
that gives
you also a lot of information
about health care services,
a lot of information
about diagnosis.
Like, for example,
you are a high risk of cancer
or highest risk of
something else,
information about
treatments and so on.
There are also ontologies for
procedure codes
as they are bill
on the provider claims.
And those are the ones that we
are mostly working
on, but, is,
yeah, it's it's
great to see all
these anthologies that are
appearing there
every every day,
basically. There
are more and more.
Cool. Thanks, Vanessa.
That's really helpful.
So we'll just give
it a second.
I can see Douglas
Moore is typing.
So just to see if we can make
for his questions
to come through.
And then if that
doesn't come through,
then, we'll probably
break for lunch.
Of course, any anyone that has
any follow-up
questions, please do,
link up with Vanessa on the on
the Slack channel.
You can you can
ask them there.
Here we are. Couple
of questions.
So was the claims processing,
a point solution for
validating claims,
or has the effort
to map source
data to greater benefits?
Not sure if So it seems to be
a question about
the claim processing.
I'm not so sure
if I'm not gonna
answer this question
correctly.
But, so the claim
processing is
something that is happening
already on the state
of the art,
and in particular
for fraud, waste,
and abuse detection
approaches.
Right? They look at outliers.
They look at
calculating the risk
of providers and so on.
So the claim data
is usually in
a very well
structured format.
Right? And in some cases,
it's also linked with health
records that give you
extra information.
Like, you can look at the care
pathway of a person,
the outcomes,
and so on.
What we try to
do here is a bit
different because we want to
understand the claims,
not by looking only
at the claim data,
but by understanding
the policy.
If the policy
says you can't do
this and you cannot do that,
and then to see
if we can execute
that on the claim
of data to see
actually what
claims they don't
seem to be doing that.
So that gives you
an indication
to the investigator
to have a look
and to explore more
and to create.
If that is the case that they
are really,
infringing policy,
they can build a case.
And in order to build a case,
they had to tell.
This is a policy
lay legislation
that these claims
are breaking.
I'm not sure if
I answered that
question well. Yeah.
I think, I I think that that,
answered that.
And then there's
another comment,
from Frederick
Frederick, Landquist,
using mesh UMLS
ICD, etcetera,
medical vocabularies.
But have you also created one
context specific
for the speaking
about the domain
and mapped this
with the other large
vocabularies?
Yeah. Yeah. That's correct.
That's the case.
So we actually
created an ontology
manually with
the domain as per us.
So we can this
ontology is the the
one that is guiding
the knowledge
extraction, and it's basically
focusing on things
that are actionable.
So I care about these entities
and these relations because
these are the things
that I can
then go to the claim data and
see if something is
compliant or not.
So that ontology
was direct was
created within that schema.
And then, however,
there is a lot of
instance data.
And for that, we
use other sources.
There is a lot of
tabular tabular data.
For example, it thinks about
describing places
of service. Right?
You can give this service in
the of in the hospital,
or you can give
this service in
this condition.
So all those codes
and all those
sources, we list them
into the ontology,
just by creating some mappings
as in as in fancy.
And we also, through
the ontology,
links to those other
terminologies.
So for example,
there may be an eligibility
criteria that says,
in order for you
to get topical
fluoride, you
need to be a high
risk of caries or cavities.
So to extract this
high risk of caries,
we use UMLS. We
say that we are
expecting something there that
may be a medical
diagnosis. Right?
And then that is the domain of
that property, and that's some
part of the eligibility
criteria.
So this is how we
do the linking
to UMLS.
It's based also it's based
basically on the semantic
hierarchy that UMLS has.
Perfect. Great.
Thanks, thanks so
much for that,
Vanessa.
Really fantastic talk.
Thanks to you, and
enjoy your lunch.
You too. Thanks. Bye.